ça ne pas décider sans hésitation
catanèse jeanne rose avance vers la
salle d'audience du tribunal
il comparaît en correctionnelle pour
faux et usage de faux escroquerie et
recel d'abus de biens sociaux notamment
dans le cadre d'une subvention de plus
de 29 mille euros du conseil régional
subventions que le maire de saint joseph
aurait indûment perçus
son avocat le bâtonnier dominique
nicolas va plaider la relaxe
vous verrez très bien à l'occasion de
l'audience et de ce qu'il en sortira que
les faits qui lui sont reprochés
les délits prétendu qu'il aurait commis
ne sont pas constitués nous plaiderons
la relaxe de monsieur atteint à jeanne
rose en octobre pour annoncer cette
affaire est politique et les attaques
viennent de son camp à part amener loin
la mairie 1
parce que ma constater que ni compétents
ni en partie et équipements bien qu'il
est léger des mois des eaux dû tourner
autant que moi là il faut qu'ils m'ont
laissé place baillaud à la maladie est
souvent m16 owni la fosse faut attaquer
ma personne mais faut convenir à la
place ficgayo mandant pays de droit si
m'a fait me virer aux affaires ma
candidature n'est pas ma vie aux
affaires vous attendez d'un bonus à
camper chez c'est en raison de l'absence
de l'avocat de gilbert vincent sully
amis d'athanase jeanne rose est aussi
accusé dans cette affaire que le dossier
a été renvoyé au 2 octobre prochain